Theo hàng thủ tận Anna Dulu và hành tin vời tơs, ngoại trường nghĩ mắc của Rubio ngày 20 năm triệu biệt,
các của đầm phán sữa Washington và Tayran đã xuất hiện một số tiến hiệu tích cực,
nhưng những mạnh con quá sớm để lạc quan về khả năng đặt đủ thoại lâu dài.
Và biểu vì bọn dưới ông Rubio triệu biệt, chính quyền tổng thống đứa năng trang đăng lưu thu dẩy mùa thuật tốt,
bởi y văn thông qua đủ thải.
Tuy nhiên ông đồng thời kánh báo, Washington vẫn còn những lựa trận khán nếu tiến chiều ngoại sao thức bạn.
Dù không điều của thế ông Rubio khẩn định, Mỹ sẵn sàng bảo vệ các lựa chính đường của mình.
Truy đó, phó tổng thống Mỹ trên đefan s cũng thuy bố, Washington sẽ không chấp nhận bất kịt vào tổn nào cho phép i raan sửu hút kiét nhận.
Theo Fox News, ông Vens Tobiet, Mỹ đã khoá một tiêu và sẵn sản khai hoạm nếu cần thiết.
Sông nhận mạnh ước tiên hiện nay vẫn là sẽ phán hội sao?
Bề phy raan theo hàng của tình cấp cao, lánh thảo tuy cầy raan đã bán hành chi thiệt,
về việc không được đường rãl yuôn xa lưng ngoài và điều này can cùng có lập chiều của tây raan,
đối với một trong những yêu cầu chính của Mỹ tại của đảng Phán Hoa Bình.
Dù lệng bán sop các thác thích dà làm trung dàng hiện và đường dưới chi,
các của đảng Phán cận đầy vẫn chưa đạm bữ đột phá đáng kể.